لم يعد للمراه في مكان في افغانستان تحت
حكم طالبان هذا ما فعلته الحركه منذ
توليها السلطه في انتهاك كافه حقوق النساء
وفرض القيود عليهم بدايه من قيود اللباس
وحرمانهن من الترفيه ودخول الصالات
الرياضيه ومن ثم المكتبات العامه والمعاهد
والاخضر حضر حقهن في التعليم الجامعي وفي
اخر القيود القاسيه على نساء منع الطالبان
المراه من العمل في المنظمات غير الحكوميه
فيما وصف بانه خرق واضح للمبادئ الانسانيه
في افغانستان
[موسيقى]
قرارات طالبان هذه الاستهداف في حريات
النساء وقمعهن وصلبهن حقوقهن قوبلت بسخطه
دوليه واسع وفي احدث الردود على قرار
طالبان الاخير علقت 4 منظمات اجنبيه غير
حكوميه عملها في افغانستان بعد حظر النساء
فيها وقالت منظمه انقذ الاطفال والمجلس
النرويجي لللاجئين ومنظمه كير ولجنه
الانقاذ الدوليه انهم لا يستطيعون مواصله
اعمال الاغاثه والمساعدات الانسانيه بدون
موظفاتهم واعتبرت منظمه الصليب الاحمر الى
منع طالبان للنساء من التعليم والعمل في
الادوار الانسانيه يمكن ان يؤدي الى
عواقبه انسانيه كارثه من جانبها دعت وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه
بعد قرارات طالبان القمعيه ضد النساء
ما دانا الاتحاد الاوروبي قرار طالبان
معلنا انه يقيم تداعيه ذلك على مساله
تقديم المساعدات لافغانستان
[موسيقى]
وفي مزيد من ردود الفعل الدوليه المهدده
بقرارات في طالبان نادى على امين العام ل-
اا المنظمه منظمه التعاون الاسلاميه طه دع
الحركه لاعاده النظر في قرار تعليق عمل
النساء في المنظمات غير الحكوميه معبرا عن
مخاوفه العميقه من تداعيت هذا القرار
من جانبه قال المتحدث الاقليمي باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه صمويل في لقاء مع
العربيه قال ان حركه طالبه بقرارها منع
نساء من التوظيف في المنظمات غير الحكوميه
ستعطي نفسها عن الشعب الافغاني والمجتمع
الدولي مضيفا ان الولايات المتحده ستبحث
مع حلفائها للرد الانسب على طالب
كل هذه القرارات فعلا تؤدي الى زياده
الاصل همم طالما من المجتمع الدولي ومن
سكان اذن همم كما قلتي همم الان كما نرى
في الافغانستان همم هذا ليس ال ال ال
السبب او ليس مسؤوليه للشعب ولكن همم
هي التي تاخذ كل هذه القرار همم الوليد
المتحده لدينا بعد الاليات واسمعنا منذ
ايام من وزير يمكن ان نحن الان سنبحث من
الخلفاءنا وشركاؤنا بالاصبع
وسيله لا ارسل ال- ال- رساله واضحه
حول هذه القرارات
ووسط موجه التمديد الدولي هذا رده طالبان
قبل قليل حيث قال المتحدث باسم طالبان ذبح
الله مجاهد ان الحركه ترفض اي تهديدنا على
خلفيه قراراتها المتعلقه بالنساء مضيفا
على طالبان ترفض ايضا تدخل امريكا بشئونها
وفي المنظمات العامله في افغانستان
من جانبه قال وزير التعليم العالي بحكومه
طالبان نداء محمد نديم ان الحركه لن
تتراجع عن قراراتها تجاه النساء حتى ولو
القيا عليهم قنبله ذريه واكد وزير التعليم
العالي بحكومه الطالبات ان الحركه مستعده
للعقوبات التي قد تفرض عليها من المجتمع
الدولي مؤكدا انهم لن يقبلوا ما وصفه
بالاملاءات من اي شخص في ما يتعلق بحقوق
المراه